well every tattoo I had I had a part and
actually like drawing it or created it
besides this one this one just the one I
picked out of the book like yeah I like
that one every other tattoo has been on
something that resonated at home with me
and I sat with the artist and drew it
I'd love to draw I love creative
expression I would draw like all over my
my test and my homework and stuff like I
would get all the answers right and get
like 15 points deducted for like
sabotaging it what's up this is Trey
Songz here at GQ to tell you about my
tattoos first tattoo I ever got was a
cross on my right arm and it reads only
god can judge me I think it was Tupac
inspired it's Tupac hat I got only god
can judge me to tattoo and pop was like
a big influence and I knew that if I had
a cross and only god can judge me that
my mom could only be but so mad so I got
it I was like 16 17 she's still mad I
don't know how many times I have cause
like this is one tattoo now even though
it was like four sittings this is a
tattooist as it has it but it all looks
the same so to me it's just one if I had
to say which tattoo of mine was my
favorite would probably tend to a much
chefs it's a prayer that I wrote it
reads to God I pray me April showers
rain on her forest and grow the strength
that started with one rose I roses my
grandmother Forrest is my younger
brother and April's my my friend and she
has the strength to raise him to be as
strong as her mother raised her to be if
that makes sense I have myself sitting
on top of the world I got this when I
was probably 18 it's me the child
version of myself I'm sitting in diapers
and I want Tim's and I had when I had I
said Virginia on it and I'm sitting on
top of the world because I had these big
dreams for myself I always felt like I
would even as a young
accomplish great things and sit on top
of the world one day there's a testament
says April's boy over top of that
April's boy is actually like one of my
companies names as well there's a storm
on the other side and the sun is shining
at the end of the storm so it kind of
means that if you can make it through
the storm the Sun will shine I have a
tattoo on my wrist that I would say is
my least favorite but it's a tattooed I
was in the moment I got it with my
girlfriend at the time and I haven't
covered it up yet so I guess that means
something within itself it's actually
our initials and a Infinity Sun and
obviously we're not together at the
moment or the infinity sign is kind of
like tricky in order to cover it up it
would have to mean something more
powerful than the love that we shed at
that moment I think it was something
that that I felt very strongly about at
the time until I feel more strong about
something else it'll be here the artist
I built the biggest bond with who worked
on my body was her name is Nellie so
shot at the Nellie for doing because the
tattoo on my back is probably the most
recognizable by my fans I got that in
2008 like shortly after I cut my braids
off so I'm sure her to know every time I
left the house my grandma would say if I
left for five minutes while I left
before a couple weeks so months where
she said watch it back
because of that I got angels on my back
and their wings are like kind of
weathered from fighting off so many
storms and you see leaves fog enough but
they still did watch my back because I
believe ain't just I watch over you do
fight many many storms many many battles
that you don't see I also have a tattoo
here but it's all in issues I was raised
mostly about women and want many men in
my family so it's the initials of all
the women that raised me from my
grandmother to other grandmother to all
my aunts
what I would say that anybody thinking
about changing their body permanently is
make sure it means something of great
significance to you I know some people
do it just for the art for the
creativity of it all but I think you
should study the artists make sure you
got somebody that you know is dope
somebody that has work that you like and
be safe because a lot of janky stuff
going on out there you end up with a
keloid this big be safe
[Music]